jack and i can start a fire on this
table
light we know that it can do some pretty
crazy things we know that it travels
really really fast we know that it can
bend
when it goes in water
but what actually is light i mean
diagrams show it as a wave but then it's
also a particle
thankfully i've got a physicist in an
elevator who's ready to enlighten me
hey alessandra hello rad
so today you're going to teach me about
light i'll do what i can can you do it
in 45 floors up and down i'm going to
try it
all right
what is light okay light is a process
that allows you to transfer energy from
one place to another using
electromagnetic radiation or photons
so you said it's a process that's excuse
me everything's a process there's all in
physics we just have energy transfer so
you roll a ball you're transferring
energy using mass if you use light
you're using this massless thing called
the photon or electromagnetic wave
okay so if i were to ask you what is
light what would you say um
the part of a wave spectrum that is
visible i have the more inclusive
approach to light light is everything
that is a moving electromagnetic wave
there is nothing especially different
about microwaves radio waves x-rays
gamma rays or visible rays
except how long the wavelength is so
microwaves are still light according to
my definition yes you wouldn't
differentiate between an ocean wave that
you surf on and the waves that you
generate in a bathtub just because
they're different sizes they're all
waves
okay but it can be an electromagnetic
magnetic wave or a photon is that
different types of light well no there
is only one light okay we're halfway
through
so how can light be a particle and a
wave so the best thing we can do is
really run experiments to check how to
describe it so someone comes along and
says i'm going to hit this object with
the light and i'm going to see what
happens on the other side when you do
that and you see funny ripple looking
things that are very reminiscent of say
a water wave hitting an object and going
on to the other side so you say look i'm
seeing ripples in the water i'm seeing
ripples in the light clearly
light is a wave okay so someone else
comes along and says okay well i've got
this other source of light that is
really really dim so it's very very
small amounts of light and on this side
i've got a photographic plate that will
tell me the instant that light hits it
it will tell me with a beat so if this
was a normal laser this is very bright
and the plate will just go
and you see this image of your ripples
on the spot so then this person turns it
down you hear a big
continue beeping because there's this
stream of stuff coming
but at some point your perfect source of
light that is as low as it can go will
start doing individual clicks and that
will be a sign that light in a sense
is an individual
particle that we call a photon
but it's an electromagnetic wave
yes no yes but how can light be a wave
and a particle well it depends who you
ask people talk about wave packets as a
way of saying that well you can describe
it as a wave or you can describe it as a
particle but
no
no i'm sorry
reality is all we've got
thought this was going to be easier than
it ended up being
i'm so sorry
that's as much as i can give you
thank you
[Music]
look i'll admit i came into this one
maybe a little bit overconfident because
i feel like i understand light or at
least i understand a lot of the
properties of light but then you start
talking about the fact that it can be
both a wave and a particle and we know
this because you can do an experiment
that shows it behaving as a wave or you
can do one that shows it behaving as a
particle and this doesn't just go for
visible light it's everything on the
electromagnetic spectrum from microwaves
to radio waves to ultraviolet and they
all have these properties and do it all
with no mass
but you know the thing that like really
really got me is when he said that light
is just a transfer of energy
what a light bulb moment
hey thanks for watching if you liked
this video there are plenty more like it
we've done the big bang time dilation
and even blockchain you can click here
to watch them and if you like this video
you can hit subscribe for plenty more
from us see ya